in this video we will understand the
concept behind histone chipseek chipseek
stands for chromatin imuno precipitation
followed by sequencing this is a
particular technique or a variant of
chromatine chipseek to understand the
hisone modifications and how that is
associated with specific
genes it's already a mouthful maybe you
don't understand so let me break it down
so we know that there are different
parts of the chromatine which which are
highly condensed known as
heterochromatin and there are some parts
of the chromatine which are less
condensed and more open towards
transcription factor or any other kind
of protein known as UK chromatine now UK
chromatine and heterochromatin has
different kind of modification and in
different video we have talked about it
right so eukroma is highly acylated in
specific residues like h3k9 H3 k14 Etc
also there are specific methylation and
phosphorilation found in this region in
contrast in heterochroma chromatine
different other modifications in the
histone are
found so let's say one ask a question
that which genes or genomic regions are
associated with h3k9 acetylation which
is known to be a activatory or basically
which is associated with Gene Activation
so question is which genes in the genome
are associated with this particular
modification we are trying to understand
a glob scenario and that is why histone
chipseek will give us the answer let's
find out how so in order to understand
that we have to basically understand the
principle of chipseek it's a technique
to study DNA protein interaction in this
particular context we are trying to
understand which histones are acylated
in a specific residue and interacting
with the DNA and which DNA it is so that
is why it's a perfect technique so
obviously this technique that is chipsi
can give us answers about transcription
Factor binding specific histone
modification epigenetic modification Etc
so it's a very powerful tool to identify
genome wide DNA binding sites for
transcription factor or let's say for
histone so we have situation one let's
say there is a specific binding location
to one particular location of the genome
there could be also another situation
where the binding location is spreading
across different locations in the genome
so we want to have a idea that where
does the protein of in rest or histone
is modified so in this example what
would happen is a particular antibody
against a particular modified histone
Mark will be used and that will be used
to basically pull down a region of the
chromatine chromatine would be sonicated
and severed into small fragments and
using this antibody which is basically
coated on a bead the portions of the
chromatine that is associated with these
histone modification will be pulled down
so this is the pull down step so from
the pull down fragment it would be then
asked that which portion of the DNA does
this modified histone bind so let's say
H3 canine acetylation binds to which
portions of the DNA in the entire
genome so what would happen after this
so after step four we were left with
specific fragments which are basically
DNA fragments so they could be detected
using hrut sequencing methods so in this
case each of these DNA sequences would
be of different size and these sequences
are known as reads now these reads would
be aligned with a reference genome so
basically these reads are significant
fragments of the genome right so you
take these reads and try to compare it
with a known human or Mouse genome
depend on the sample that we are using
and then we align this reads with
respect to the genome to ask the
question that okay which gene or genetic
sequences is associated with this kind
of protein so basically a peak would be
called and this peak is basically number
of reads in a particular location so how
does the data look like there would be a
genomic track in the bottom and on the
top there would be Peak so where you see
a high height of the peak that means at
that particular point of region your
protein of Interest had bound to the DNA
in this case the peak is very strong at
the promoter in this particular given
example now let's come back to our own
example so we ask which gene or genomic
regions are associated with histone
h3k9 acylation so this is how the
hypothetical data look like you can see
there are in the genomic tract there are
different different genes like Gene a b
c d e f to Gene n and you can see from
this data set the are giving us an idea
where does this particular histone
modification was found and in which
genomic location from this context you
can see that chip Peaks are found in
gene a d and e so Gene a D and E are
associated with h3k9 Mark so this is how
this chipseek data is very useful now
what I talked about in this particular
example is a very simple context now
there could be complicated context like
we are looking for multiple histone
modifications and many other things
together to get a deeper understanding
about the gene regulation for example in
this context you can see for this
particular Gene which is marked in um
bluish green you can see the h3k27
acylation Mark is detected throughout
the gene body then in a separate
experiment but all these data are
colleted together in the separate
experiment one looked for age 3.3
histone Peak PE also looked at h2z
histone Peak so h3.3 h2z all are
associated with actively transcribing
genes also serin 5 phosphate
modification is found on the RNA
polymerase which is a indicative of
active Gene so if one can detect serin
five phosphate phosphate Associated chip
peaks in that location and compare all
of these things together then then we
can say that this particular Gene
whatever is described here here is
actively transcribing one can even
compare this with an RNA Peak to really
understand whether the mrnas are
produced or not so this is how we can
combine different different chipseek
again against different histone
components to get a deeper understanding
about transcriptional regulation now
it's not only about the chipseek
chipseek can be combined with other
techniques for example in this case
chips there there could be different
different chips that we have described
here also chipseek can be combined with
ax attack sequencing is another
particular technique which talks about
the accessibility of the chromatine also
CH chips can be combined with RNA
sequencing as well RNA sequencing look
for all the transcripts of a particular
Gene in a global context in a genomewide
scale so it's a transcriptomic technique
so combining all these data we can get a
deeper inside in this case we see neuron
and fibroblast are compared and compared
for what compared for Gene a expression
so notice the top side so I'll take a
pointer and explain so notice the top
side here you can see there is a strong
chip Peck for a particular um
transcription factor and you can see
that particular transcription Factor
binds to this particular region of the
DNA and not only that the attack Peaks
are pretty much like the chip picks
attack Pi simply tell us there are more
accessibility so so this two portions
are the data and this is how the the
phenomena would actually look like in a
graphical fashion so if you look at the
F blast tracks you don't see too much of
uh chip Peak or attack peak in that
corresponding region that means that
particular transcription factor of
Interest doesn't bind to Gene a and
doesn't lead to the transcription and
this data is also reflected in the RNs
if there is less transcription obviously
there would be less transcripts so the
expression profile is understood using
using RNA sequencing the accessibility
was understood using atoxic and the
transcription Factor binding or a
protein binding was figured out using
chipstick this is how multimodality was
used together to understand deeper
insight about transcription of Gene
regulation so here is some application
of histone chipsi or in general chipsi
so obviously generally chipsi can detect
transcription Factor binding epigenetic
modification histone modification
profiling can be done which we have seen
as an example in this video also
identifying enhancer promoters
identifying specific genomic regions and
also disease related studies or which of
the marks are associated with disease
these kind of studies can be done using
histone chipsi or chromatin imun
precipitation so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up you can get more notes
and flash cards in our Facebook and
Instagram page see you in next
video